[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
هذه اللقطات من مكه المكرمه واجواء الحرم
المكي في شهر رمضان المبارك
[موسيقى]
وهذه الصور من المسجد الاقصى اجواء يعيشها
الناس هناك الان بعيدا انتهاء صلاه
التراويح
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
استمرار اقتحامات المستوطنين لباحات
الاقصى السلطه الفلسطينيه تحذر من محاولات
التغيير الوضع القائم مسؤول اسرائيلي بارز
يعرب عن قلقه من تداعيات ما وصفها
بالاعتداءات المبالغ فيها للشرطه في
الاقصى زعيم المعارضه يشدد على ان حكومه
نتنياهو غير مؤهله للتعامل مع الوضع
الامني الحالي ويطالب باقاله
للمره الاولى الصين تواصل مناوراتها تحاكي
شن هجمات على تايوان
تاهب في وحديث امريكي عن ارسال قوات
امريكيه للدفاع عن الجزيره وعقد زيارته
الى بيجين ماكرو يدعو الى عدم الجرار
اوروبا وراء واشنطن في مواجهتها المحتمل
مع الصين
الوثائق المسربه تضع واشنطن في مازق مع
حلفائها البنتا يفرض قيودا صارمه على تدفق
المعلومات قلق اوروبي من احتمال تعليق
مشاركه التقارير الاستخباريه وكوريا
الجنوبيه تعتزم بحث تداعيات التسريبات
بشان مناقشات حول تزويدها اوكرانيا باسلحه
موضوع تداعيات تسريب الوثائق التي تبعناه
قبل قليل كنا قد نقشنا معكم عن هذه
الوثائق حيث كان حاضرا كما ذكرت في لقائنا
اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا الرقميه
حيث ناقشنا محاوله واشنطن احتوائه والتحقق
في اسبابه فيما نفت اسرائيل ما جاء فيها
عن وقوف المصاد وراء المظاهرات المناهضه
للتعديلات القضائيه بينما اعلنت صول عزمها
بحثه داعيه الوثائق المسربه مع المسؤولين
الامريكيين لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع قلنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي هل سيؤثر تسريب الوثائق من
الفانتاجون على علاقه واشنطن بحلفائها
خمسه وخمسون في المئه قالوا نعم ثلاثه
وثلاثون في المئه اجابوا بلا بينما راى
15% انها ستؤثر على تبادل المعلومات هذا
السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار
الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا وكذلك دوليا
[موسيقى]
ترقب مستمر نحو المسجد الاقصى اذ يسود
توتر والخشيه من اقتحامات جديده قد تنفذها
قوه الاحتلال صباح اليوم كان اكثر من 900
مستوطن ومتطرف يهودي اقتحبوا المسجد
الاقصى صباح اليوم في رابع ايام عيد الفصح
اليهودي بحمايه من شرطه الاحتلال سبق ذلك
اقتحام شرطه الاحتلال باحات المسجد عقب
صلاه الفجر وانتشروا في بحاته بهدف تامين
ما يعرف بصله بركه الكهنه التي يشارك فيها
الاف اليهود في ساحه حائط البراق الملاصق
للمسجد الاقصى هذا ويتوقع ان تتواصل
اقتحامات مستوطنين والمتطرفين الاقصى
باعداد كبيره يوم غد الاثنين تلبيه لدعوات
اطلقتها منظمات يهوديه متطرفه لتكثيف
الاقتحامات في باقي ايام عيد الفصح
الياقودي الذي
يوم الاربعاء
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه حذرت من مخاطر زياده
اعداد المشاركين في اقتحامات المسجد
الاقصى وتداعيات حملات التحريض المتواصله
والممنهجه ضد القدس ومقدساتها واعتبرت
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه الاعتداء الاسرائيليه
المتواصل على المسجد الاقصى امتدادا
لمحاوله تغيير واقعه القانوني وكذلك
التاريخي وطلبت مجلس الامن الدولي باتخاذ
ما يلزم من الخطوات العمليه لتنفيذ
القرارات الامميه
اما الاردن الذي تعود اليه الوصايه على
الاماكن المقدسه في القدس فحمل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه التصعيد وقالت
الخارجيه الاردنيه ان حكومه اسرائيل
ستتحمل مسؤوليه تدهور الاوضاع في حال لم
توقف الاقتحامات في الاقصى وتضيقها على
المصلين واضافت ان الاقتحامات تمثل خرقا
لوضع التاريخي والقانوني القائم في المسجد
الاقصى وانتهاكا لحرمه الاماكن المقدسه
من جبل الزيتون في القسمه على من هناك
مراسلة للجزيره امين كيف هو الوضع في ظل
هذه الاوضاع المتشنجه
عبد القادر انتهت قبل نحو 20 دقيقه صلاه
التراويح بمشاركه
نحو 25 الف مصلي هنا في باحات المسجد
الاقصى طبعا كان هناك تراقب حذر خلال صلاه
التراويح لكن
هناك مشاورات الان على المستوى الاسرائيلي
للبث في مساله مواصله عمليه الاقتحامات
خلال العشره الاواخر من شهر رمضان المبارك
وهناك وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه قالت بان كل
من وزير الدفاع المقال وايضا وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي
طلبوا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بالسماح للمستوطنين والمتطرفين
باقتحام المسجد الاقصى خلال العشر الاواخر
لكن وسائل اسرائيليه ايضا اكدت على ان
نتنياهو ما زال لم يتخذ قرارا بهذا الشان
وذلك يتوقف بحسب تلك المصادر على مسالتين
رئيسيتين الاولى هي مدى جهوزيه الشرطه
القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في التعامل
مع عمليات الاقتحام من تامينها ومواجهه اي
استفزاز قد يترتب عنه طبعا هنا في المسجد
الاقصى والمساله الثانيه تتوقف على
التطورات التي سيشهدها المسجد الاقصى خلال
اليومين المقبلين وخاصه يوم الاربعاء وهو
اليوم الاخير في عيد الفصح
اليهودي طبعا
وسائل الاعلام ايضا اسرائيليه نقلت عن
مسؤول رفيع اسرائيلي قوله ان الوضع قابل
للاشتعال في المسجد الاقصى وان التدخل
العنيف لق الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ليله الاربعاء الماضي اضر كثيرا بصوره
اسرائيل وانه سيتم فتح تحقيق في ذلك لكن
هناك تقديرات من الشرطه الاسرائيليه في
المقابل على ان اليومين المقبلين قد يكون
هناك هدوء في المسجد الاقصى والكل الان
بات يدرك بان
التوتر
وضبط حاله التوتر طبعا واي تصعيد حول
المسجد الاقصى بل وفي اسرائيل طبعا يتوقف
على الوضع كيف سيكون بالتحديد في المسجد
الاقصى وهناك طبعا مطالب ودعوات من قبل
مجموعات متطرفه للخروج في مسيره استفزازيه
غدا في شمال الضفه من الغربيه الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه دانت هذه الدعوات خاصه وانها
يتوقع ان تشهد مشاركه اعضاء في الكنيست
الاسرائيلي وايضا وزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من جبل الزيتون في القدس
مراسله الجزيره امين شكرا جزيلا لك
رغم الادانات العربيه والدوليه تعتمد
اسرائيل سياسه فرض الامر الواقع في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك وتحويل التقسيم الزمري
والمكاني الى حقيقه في مخالفه لبابات يعرف
بالوضع التاريخي القائم للاماكن المقدسه
فما الذي يعنيه التقسيم الزمالي والمكان
وكيف تحاول اسرائيل فرضه نتعرف على ذلك في
التقرير التالي
شكل عام 2003 نقطه تحول في اقتحامات
المستوطنين اليهود للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
انذاك سمحت شرطه الاحتلال للمستوطنين
باقتحامه تحت حمايتها كامر واقع التقسيم
الزمني الذي تحاول اسرائيل فرضه يعني
تخصيص اوقات محدده لدخول المسلمين
واخرى خاصه باليهود باغتسام الساعه
والايام طوال العام
بموجبه بات على المسلمين افراغ المسجد
الاقصى لساعات محدده يوميا ليصلي اليهود
ثلاث صلوات في الاقصى
وتسعى اسرائيل الى تخصيص المسجد الاقصى
لليهود خلال اعيادهم التي تصل الى 100 يوم
وجميع ايام السبت
والتقسيم المكاني هو تخصيص مناطق وزوايا
معينه من المسجد الاقصى لكل من الطرفين
حيث تسعى الحكومه الاسرائيليه لاقتطاع
منطقتين ينظر الى محاولات اسرائيل لفرض
التقسيم الزمني والمكني كخرق للوضع
التاريخي القائم الذي ساد في فتره الدوله
العثمانيه ثم الانتداب البريطاني والحكم
الاردني وصولا الى بدايه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عام 67
وبموجبه فان الصلاه في المسجد تقتصر على
المسلمين وحدهم ويمكن لغير المسلمين
زيارته سياحا فقط
ولتنفيذ مخططاتها تعتمد اسرائيل على قانون
القوه
تعمد لابعاد المصلين لاشهر تمنع منهم دون
الاربعين من الصلاه في الاقصى تحضر ما
تسميه تنظيم المرابطين والمرابطات
وتعتدي على المعتكفين
هذا واثار التصعيد الاسرائيلي في المسجد
الاقصى تساؤلات بشان اهدافه في وقت تشهد
فيه اسرائيل ازمه داخليه تهدد بتفكك
الائتلاف الحكومي وابدت المعارضه تخوفاتها
من تدهور الوضع الامني وقال الزعيمها رئيس
الحكومه السابق بعد طلقه احاطه امنيه انه
وصل الى الاجتماع قلقا وخرج منه اكثر قلقا
وقال انه ابلغ نتنياهو ان حكومه متطرفه لن
تكون قادره على اداره هذه المرحله وان
وزير الامن
متفرغ
وينبغي توقيف سلطاته في القدس
مشهدان لا يمكن الفصل بينهما المشهد الاول
اقتحام جنود الاحتلال المسجد الاقصى
واعتدائهم على المصلين والمعتكفين
والمشهد الثاني المظاهرات الرافده
للتعديلات القضائيه لحكومه طنياهو
اليمينيه المتطرفه اصبح اقتحام الاقصى
سلوكا اسرائيليا يتكرر كل سنه لكن ما يميز
هذه السنه ان حكومه نتنياهو تواجه ازمه
داخليه عميقه بعد ان تحرك الشارع ضد
تعديلات قضائيه تقلص دور المحكمه العليا
فارغم نتنياهو على تاجيل البث فيها معتبره
انصار حكومته من اقصى اليمين هزيمه
لتخفيف ضغط هؤلاء الانصار اصبح نتنياهو في
حاجه لتحقيق انجاز عبر تصعيد ضد
الفلسطينيين على ما يبدو هنا المكان
والزمان لهما رمزيه كبيره المسجد الاقصى
ورمضان المبارك يحاول نتنياه تحقيق هدفين
الاول مرتبط بالثاني وضع راهن جديد في
المسجد الاقصى من خلال خلق جو مناسب
للاقتحامات والصلوات التلموديه والضغط
لتقديم القرابين ومن خلال خلق هذا الجو
ارضاء انصار حكومته من المتديين ما يخفف
التوتر داخل ائتلافه الحكومي ويبعد شبح
سقوطه يسعى نتنياهو لتفادي هذا السقوط بكل
الوسائل لان هناك قضايا ضده امام المحاكم
ستتحرك اذا فقد منصبه يستغل حلفائه
المتطرفون في الاعتراف نقطه ضعفه هذه
ويضغطون لتحقيق مطالبهم تعرف المعارضه هذا
الوضع وتتخوف من تبعاته فقد قال زعيمها
رئيس الحكومه السابق يا ايرلقيد بعد تلقيه
احاطه امنيه من نتنياهو انه وصل الى
الاجتماع قلقا وخرج منه اكثر قلقا وذهب
ابعد من ذلك مطالبا بتشكيل طاقم امني مصغر
جديد قادر على التعامل مع الوضع الامني
المتازم قبل هذا التصعيد قال لابيل ان من
اوكل الحرم القدسي الى وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي لتمار بن غفير كان يعلم بان
الامر سيؤدي الى كارثه خلف الاعتداء على
المصلين والمعتكفين موجه السنكار واسعه
لكن ما اقلق الحكومه الاسرائيليه اكثر هي
الصواريخ التي انطلقت من جنوب لبنان
استهدفت شمال اسرائيل وتلك التي انطلقت من
غزه واستهدفت بلدات في غلافها ورغم ان هذه
الضربات بقيت في اطار التحذير من مزيد من
التصعير في الاقصى فقد كان لافتا ان الرد
الاسرائيلي كان محدودا بالمقاييس الامنيه
الاسرائيليه ويظهر هذا الرد ان نتنياهو لا
يريد حربا مفتوحه ولكن يريد تحقيق مكاسب
محسوبه دون مخاطر هذا الرد لم يرق لب
الغفير الذي طالب بالرد بقوه اكبر على
صواريخ غزه والتوقف عما اسماه تفجير كتبان
رمليه واستهداف رؤوس في غزه في اشاره الى
قاده الفصائل الفلسطينيه لا يستطيعون
تنياه مسيره بن غفير وباقي المتشددين في
ائتلافه الحكومي لكنه غير قادر ايضا على
رفض كل مطالبهم وهذا ما يجعل هامش
المناوره امامه محدودا
هذا ونقلت القناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه عن مسؤول اسرائيليا رفيع قوله
ان صور اعتداءات الشرطه في الحرب القدسي
مروعه والحقت ضررا كبيرا لاسرائيل واوضح
المسؤول الاسرائيلي حسب القناه الثانيه
عشر انه لم يطرا اي تغيير على سياسه
اسرائيل بشان الحرب القدسي واضاف ان
الشرطه اضطرت الى الدخول الى المسجد
الاقصى لكن الاعتداءات كان مبالغا فيها
وسيتم تحقيق في ذلك واشار الى ان الوضع
قابل للاشتعال والسلطه الفلسطينيه ضعيفه
وما يحدث في المسجد الاقصى هو ما سيحدد ما
اذا كانت هناك الموجه من التوتر هذه
الموجه من التوتر ستستمر ام انها ستتلاشى
من الناصره معنا وديع ووداء الكاتب الصحفي
المتخصص في الشان الاسرائيلي سيد وديع
العندي التقط معك ما قاله زعيم المعارضه
قال دخلت الاجتماع مع نتنياهو قالقا وخرجت
من هذا الاجتماع اكثر قلقا ما الذي فهمته
من ذلك
نعم هذا القول ينطوي على اكثر من دلاله
اولها في المستوى الامني لا يغير لبيد
يدركه وهو رئيس حكومه حتى قبل ثلاثه شهور
وهو على صله ما يجري بصفه رئيس المعارضه
في دوائر اسرائيل الامنيه وهو يدرك ما كان
قد ادركه واعلن عنه وزير الامن جلند قبل
اسبوعين وبسببه تمت الاطاحه به من ان هناك
ما يعرف بتلاحم او التحام الساحات
والجبهات الفلسطينيه والعربيه المحيطه
باسرائيل وان الاوضاع متفجره نتيجه عند
عده عوامل منها وجود حكومه في غايه التطرف
حكومه يمنيه يهوديه عنصريه غيبيه تعمل على
تقاسم الاقصى كما كنتم في تقريركم هناك
وزراء يضعون الاصبع في عيون الفلسطينيين
يتعاملون مع الفلسطيني بفتره واستعلائيه
وهناك بالاضافه الى كل ذلك ازمات داخليه
كلها تنذر يعني وجود مخاطر وتهديدات
حقيقيه
ورغم اختلال موازين القوى يدرك لبيد
وبالتجربه ادرك ذلك ان وجود سبعه الى
ثمانيه ملايين فلسطيني من البحر الى النهر
لا تستطيع اسرائيل ان تبقى تتعامل معهم
بهذا الغلو بهذه الغطرسه وحينما على ما
يبدو قام اللبيد بمسائله كيف يمكن ان يضع
برميل البارود هذا حسب المصطلح السياسي
الاسرائيلي وهو يعني الحرم القدسي الشريف
بيدي مشعل النار بيد هذا المهرج بيد هذا
الارهابي وزير الامن القومي
بن غفير هذا لابد ان يعني ولا نتحدث عن
نبيتك قد تلقى اجابه من قبل نتنياهو انه
عازم على المواصله بهذه السياسه ودافع عن
بنجافير لانه لا توجد نتنياهو الكثير من
الخيارات
وهو امام خيارات صعبه جدا ان كان يمتثل
للبيد وللمعارضه وللشارع الاسرائيلي
بضروره التهدئه والتعامل بحكمه وعدم
استنساخ سيناريو هبت الكرامه في 20 21
حينما التحمت كل الساحات الفلسطينيه ضد
الاحتلال سيجد نفسه بدون حكومه ولذلك هو
يعني خرج لبيد وقال انه دخل كاليكان
وخرج اكثر قلقا من الناصره وديع واودع
الكاتبه الصحفيه المتخصص في الشان
الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك
سيكون لنا حديث اوسع عن اسرائيل وسنتطرق
الى الجبهات المتعدده وكيف تقرا الجبهات
التي وقعت مؤخرا من جنوب لبنان ومن سوريا
[موسيقى]
تسارعت التطورات في محيط جزيره تايوان في
اليوم الثاني من مناورات السيف الحاد التي
تجريها الصين بحرا وجوا واجرت القوه
الصينيه للمره الاولى تمرينات تحاكي شان
هجمات على اهداف داخل تايوان في غضون ذلك
نقلت رويترز عن مسؤول عسكري صيني ان سفنا
حربيه صينيه واخرى تايوانيه اصبحت في وضع
مواجهه قرب مضيق تايوان لكن ايا منها لم
تبدي سلوكا استفزازيا
تريدها الصين رساله واضحه لتايوان ولمن
يدعمها حول الجزيره تجري مناورات السيف
الحاد التي يجريها الجيش الصيني بقواته
البحريه والجويه
للمره الاولى تحاكي تنفيذ ضربات دقيقه على
اهداف رئيسيه داخل الجزيره لافي المياه
المحيطه بها فقط تشمل المناورات الصينيه
تطويقا كاملا لجزيره تايوان واحكام
السيطره على البحر والمجال الجوي
والاتصالات لاحداث قوه رادعه باستخدام
اسلحه هجوميه
تضمنت التمرينات تنفيذ مدمرات وفرقاطات
وزوارق صاروخيه سريعه وقاذفات صواريخ من
السواحل الصينيه هجوما على مناطق جنوب غرب
تايوان باسلحه دقيقه التوجيه رافقتها في
ذلك طائرات الانذار المبكر وطائرات
استطلاع الى جانب طائرات مقاتله وطائرات
التشويش التي حلقت في الاجواء المستهدفه
واخترقت بعض القاذفات المجال الجويه
التايواني على ارتفاعات منخفضه
[تصفيق]
ما يجري حولها اكدت وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه وانها تراقب الانشطه الصاروخيه
للصين وان قواتها للدفاع الجوي تحافظ على
درجه عاليه من اليقظه وفي حاله تاهب قصوى
هذه الصور لتدريبات اجراها اللواء المدرع
542 التابعوا للجيش التايواني تدريبات
اتخذت طابعا دفاعيا بالدبابات والعربات
المدرعه وعربات همفي جرت في مقاطعه
سنشوشماليه الجزيره بينما كانت المناورات
الصينيه تجريف البحر والجو تصعيد يرفع
مستواه حديث رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
بمجلس وابل امريكي مايكل ماكول الذي قال
ان ارسال قوات امريكيه الى تايوان قد يكون
امرا محتملا اذا ما غزت الصين الجزيره وان
هذا الامر سيكون مطروحا على الطاوله
وسيناقشه
تاتي المناورات الصينيه قرب تايوان في كل
مره للرد على اي تقارب بين واشنطن فقد
فعلت بيجين مثل ذلك شهر اغسطس من العام
الماضي عندما زارت رئيسه مجلس النواب
الامريكي حينها ننسب لوسي جزيره تايوان
لكن المختلفه هذه المره ان التدريبات
الصينيه تجري في مياه قريبه من جزر ماتسو
التي تسيطر عليها تايوان وتنشر فيها قوات
للحمايه من هجوم صيني محتمل ووفقا لمصدر
تحدث فان نحو 20 سفينه عسكريه نصفها صيني
ونصفها الاخر من تايوان موجوده وجها لوجه
بالقرب من الخط الاوسط لمضيق تايوان لكنها
لم تبدي اي سلوك استفزازي
متابعه لهذا الملف معنا من نيويورك فيكتور
جاو نائب رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه ومن
الصحفي ومؤسس مجله نيو بلوم في تايوان
اهلك وابدا بضيفي من ضيفي السيد برايم هيو
سيد هيو مناورات
تمثل عمليه المحاصره للجزيره وهذا اليوم
مناورات تشكل او مضمونها هجوم على تايوان
كيف وجدتم هذه التحركات وهذه المناورات
الصينيه
هذه محاوله للترهيب النفسي فما تريده
الصين هو تسيطر على تايوان بدون اقتحام
بدون
اذن تكبد الخسائر والارواح اذا تريد ان
تحتل تايوان لكي تستفيد اقتصاديه وبالتالي
تريد ان تهبط معنويات الشعب التايواني فما
يسهل عليها احتلال تايوان وما هو الهدف او
هذا هو الهدف من هذه المناورات اذن
هذا طبعا لا يؤثر على الشعب في تايوان فقد
اعتادوا هذه الممارسات الصينيه
لاسيما بعدما حصل في هونغ كونغ في 2019
وبعد الازمه في اوكرانيا هل افهمك وابقى
معك سيدي ضيفي من قطيفه هل هفا منك لان لا
تنظر بكثير من
الجديه او الحذر لهذه المناورات الصينيه
ومضمونها
نعم لانه هناك ردود او ليست تماما من عفوا
هناك ردود عسكريه يوميه
تقوم بها تايوان وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه
تطلق عدد من هذه الفيديوهات التي نراها
الان التي تظهر
المراقبه هذه المناورات لكي نظهر ان
تايوان
بانها ليست في موقع المعتدي وبالتالي هذه
محاوله لكي نهدئ الوضع ولكي نحمل الصين
على عدم زياده التوتر اما بالنسبه الى
الشعب فقد اعتاد محاولات التاريخيه هذه
نحن نركز اكثر على موضوع الانتخابات بدلا
من داخل الصين بدلا من هذه المناوره ضيفي
من ماذا تريد بيجين ان تقول بشكل مباشر
وواضح ولا لبس فيه من خلال هذه المناورات
اولا انه من الواضح تماما ان زياده
التوترات في هذه المنطقه
والتوتر في العلاقات والنتيجه مباشره
لزياره
الرئيس
التايوانيه الولايات المتحده ولقائها
برئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي هناك هذا
انتهاك كبير للسياسه الصين الواحده وهذا
هو يعتبر الذي اطلق هذه الجوله من
المناورات العسكريه هذه الامارات
الممارسات العسكريه لن تتوقف وتنتهي
بسيطره اكبر للصين على كل الجزيره جزيره
تايوان في المستقبل
الصين ستبدا بماسات عدد من حقوقها على
تايوان في الوقت المناسب وفي كل مره يحصل
فيها انتهاك للسلامه الاراضي والسياده
الصينيه فان مناوره العسكريه وسيطر عسكريه
تزداد الى ان نصل الى نقطه نكون فيها ارض
فصاليون في تايوان في حاله ياس ويجد اي
فائده او اي جدوى لمحاولاتهم
للدعوه والطلبه استقلال للتايوان لن يعتد
تعترف اي دوله في العالم تايوان ليست جزء
لا يتجزا من الصين
سياسه معترف بها من قبل كل دول العالم وهي
هذا وابقى وابقى معك باشارتك واشنطن
واشنطن ردت ببيان على هذه المناورات حذرت
بيجيم واكدت مره اخرى التزامه التزامها
بالتزاماتها الامنيه مع الجانب التايواني
بدايه
1980 الصين كانت واضحه والدعوه الى
التوحيد بطريقه سلميه
لكن
لكنهم هناك يريدون تحقيق استقلال منفصل
للتايوان
التحدث وكانهم الدوله وانفصاليه مستقله
لوحدها وليست محافظه من محافظات الصين هذا
هو الخط الاحمر الذي لم تسمح به الصين
للمفصلين ان يتجاوزوا وانهم المتحدثين مثل
رئيس المجلس النواب الامريكي ينتهك
السياسه الامريكيه التي تعترف بسياسه
الصين الواحده وان تايوان هي جزء من الصين
وهذا هو السبب الحقيقي لزياده توترات عبر
مضيقه تايوان طيب من الطائفها هل افهم من
كلامك ومرضت به قبل قليل ان
ستواصل
نهجها اليوم الرئيس التايوان
التقت مع رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي هل
ستواصل هذا النهج مهما كان مستوى ومضمون
اي مناورات عسكريه تقوم بها الصين
المناورات هدفها الترهيب
وهذه المره هي كانت مختلفه ما حصل في
اغسطس من تمرينات حيه
ولكنني اعارض ما تفضل به الدكتور جاو انا
تايوان كانت
مسيطره مسيطره عليهم قبل الصين
من العام 1887
لمده 15 عاما هذا كل ما سيطرت عليه الصين
من حقبه زمنيه على تايوان هي تحاول ان
تظهر بانها الاقوى من خلال هذه المناورات
وانا لا اتوقع من الحكومه الديمقراطيه في
تايوان تخضع للصين هناك عقود من التهديدات
التي جعلت الشعب في تايوان يتوقف عن
التاثر بهذه المحاولات
هل سيد بريان هل تراهن تايبي على واشنطن
هل تراهن على واشنطن في حساباتها مع بيجين
نعم لانه تاريخيا الضمانه الامنيه كانت من
خلال واشنطن ولكن بعد اجتياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا كان هناك نظر في سيناريوهات
اخرى مثل ان تقف تايوان لوحدها ضد الصين
بدون تدخل الولايات المتحده مباشره مع
الدعم العسكري الامريكي ولكن حين ننظر الى
الازمه في اوكرانيا نستقي منها الكثير من
الدروس
فنحن راينا الكثير من الخسائر
وتحدثت ايضا او ارد اردت ان اتحدث ايضا عن
التابعات الاقتصاديه وبالتالي في حال نشوب
اي حرب على الصين ان تدرك ان هذه التابعات
سوف تتكبدها هي ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك من الصحفي ومؤسس مجله
نيوبلوم في تايوان وكذلك لضيفي من نيويورك
فيكتور جاو نائب رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه
عرفت الصين طيله العقود الماضيه بسياساتها
الدفاعيه الحذره وهو امر بدات معالم
تغييره في الظهور تحت زعامه الرئيس تشير
ولكن كيف حدث ذلك التقرير التالي لاحمد
بال ولد الدين
لم تعد الصين تخفي مخالبها كما عودت
العالم لعقود
تنشغل برسم صوره مهيبه لوجهها الجديد تقول
من خلالها انها لم تعد ورشه للبضائع فحسب
بل غدت قوه عسكريه لا تسمح للاغراب
بالاقتراب
تنشغل بتدريبات بحريه بعيده زياره رئيسه
تايوان للولايات المتحده يعلن التلفزيون
الحكومي ان تلك التدريبات تحاكي ضرب اهداف
رئيسيه في تايوان
الجيش الصيني يقول ان تدريبات ضروريه
لحمايه سياده الصين وقطع الطريق على
التواطؤ بين الانفصاليين والقوى الخارجيه
لكن هذا العنفوان العسكري يراه الصينيون
ايضا جزءا مما يسمونه نهضه الامه الصينيه
التي يحميها مليونان جندي
يسعى الرئيس الصيني الى محو اثار ما يعرف
عند الصينيين بفتره الاذلال
وهي اشاره الى حقبه ضعف الصين وتدخلات
الغربيين فيها قبل عقود
لذلك كان الرئيس الصيني حريصا في اول خطاب
له بعد تسلمه لفتره رئاسيه ثالثه على
القول ان على الجيش الصيني ان يكون دائما
مستعدا للقتال وهي جمله تمثل خروجا بينا
على مصطلحات السياسه الصينيه التقليديه
التي ارساها الزعيم دينك شوبينج في شعاره
الشهير اخفق قدراتك وابتعد عن الاضواء ولا
تحاول ان تقود
نسيت الصين كل ذلك وبدات في اظهار جبروتها
العسكري كما قامت المضاعفه انفاقها
العسكري منذ عام 2012 ليصل الى اكثر من
200 مليار دولار
ليست تايوان مصدر القلق الوحيد فالنات
يتوسع شرقا على كل حال
وهي حقيقه تجعل بعض الصينيين يرون فكره
التقوقع خلف السور الصين العظيم جزءا من
الماضي
فلابد من قوه رادعه ومن التقارب مع اقوياء
اخرين
وبعد زياره الى الصين قال الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمارون ان على اوروبا ان تقلص ارتباطها
بالولايات المتحده وان تتجنب الدخول في
مواجهه محتمله مع بيجين في قضيه تايوان
واضاف ماكرون انما وصفه بالخطر الكبير
بالنسبه لاوروبا هو ان تجد نفسها تنجر الى
ازمات ليست ازماتها ما سيمنعها من بناء
استقلاليتها الاستراتيجيه وحذر من ان
الاسوا هو الاعتقاد بان الاوروبيين يجب ان
يصبحوا اتباعا في هذا الملف
من بيج اعاد باقتناع لن نميل كل الميل
استقلاليه القرار الاوروبي من ازمه تايوان
هو ما ينادي به الرئيس الفرنسي
يعتبر ان الخطر الاكبر الذي تواجهه اوروبا
هو التورط في ازمات يقول انه لا علاقه لها
بها
ويحذر من ان الاسوء هو الاعتقاد بان
الاوروبيين يجب ان يصبحوا اتباعا لواشنطن
في هذا الملف
يريد ماكرون هنا امرين تجنب المواجهه
المحتمله مع الصين بشان تايوان وتقليص
ارتباط اوروبا بالولايات المتحده في هذا
الملف ليس الملف الوحيد الذي تجد فيه
باريس تحاول الاحجام مع المسايره واشنطن
فالفرنسيون يشددون صراحه على ضروره ان
تقاوم الدول الاوروبيه الضغوط التي تسعى
لتحويلها الى تبعيات امريكيه
يعتقدون ان دول الاتحاد ينبغي ان تقلل من
اعتمادها على الدولار خارج اقليمها ويرون
ان تلك الدول زادت من تبعيتها لواشنطن في
قطاعات الطاقه والتكنولوجيا والدفاع
لذا يدعوها الرئيس الفرنسي مثلا للتركيز
في المدى القريب على تعزيز الصناعات
الدفاعيه الاوروبيه وصولا الى استقلال في
السياسات الامنيه
فاوروبا اقوى ستكون في فهم فرنسا اكثر
استقلاليه داخل النيتو لكنها يجب الا
تعتمد عليه فحسب ما تقوله فرنسا جهرا ظلت
تردده بعض الاصوات الاوروبيه الاخرى همسه
انه توجه لم يبدا اليوم داخل البيت
الاوروبي لاعاده صياغه نظريه الحكم الذاتي
الاستراتيجي لاوروبا في القاره يتنامى
مثلا ذاك الشعور بانه تم توريطها في حرب
اوكرانيا بحسابات لا تراعي مصالحها
حين تفجرت ازمه الطاقه على خلفيه ذلك
الصراع لم يخفي الفرنسيون امتعاظهم مما
بدا لهم استغلالا امريكيا للموقف بتسعير
الغاز كيفما شاؤوا سجل الاوروبيون ابتعادا
اخر من حزمه الدعم الهائله التي اقرها
الكونجرس لحمايه المصنعين الامريكيين وتلك
سياسه حمائيه يخشى ان تلحق بالغ الضرر
بصناعات اوروبا واستثماراتها لا يعرف مدى
اثر كل ذلك في العلاقات الاوروبيه
الامريكيه التي تشكل عاملا اساسيا في
منظومه العلاقات الدوليه لكن باريس ظلت
تقود قاطره الاستياء من نهج شريك الضفه
الاخرى من الاطلسي لم تكن تلك العلاقات
بافضل حال في عهد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب في سعيه لتخفيف اعباء الدور
الدولي لبلاده
اما السياسات خلفه جو بايدن فمنها ما يثير
قلقا في اوروبا ما عادت تداريه
معنى من باريس باتريك الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن باريس ايضا جيم نائب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق لشؤون
اوروبا اهلا بكم ابدا بضيف باريس او
باتريك
ما صرح به الرئيس ماكرون فيما يتعلق بازمه
تايوان هو موقف فرنسي ام اوروبي
تصريحه مكروف تصريح فرنسي لانه رئيس فرنسا
ولكنه يتحدث باسم اوروبا او على الاقل هذا
ما يقوله
وبالتالي يتمنى
ان لا تقوم اوروبا
باتباعي
السياسه الامريكيه تجاه اصيل لا سيما
بالنسبه لقضيه تايوان يريد فك هذه التبعيه
كما يقول ومن ثم يتحدث عن الاستقلاليه في
هذا المجال ويتحدث عن عدم الضغط من اجل
توصل الى مواجهه بما يضع اوروبا في
الواجهه
اذا هذا موقف
ليس مختلفا عن اوروبا ولكنه ربما في الوسط
وهذا هو الخيار الذي اعتمده من خلال
الاستمرار في التواصل مع الولايات المتحده
ولكن مع الحفاظ على استقلال استراتيجي كما
تحدث كما ذكر وتحدث عن هذا الموضوع منذ
2017 حين انتخب للمراه الاولى رئيسا
لفرنسا وهنا
يذكر الاستقلاليه والاستقلال الاستراتيجي
حول قضايا اساسيه مثل
التسلح المواد الاوليه موضوع التكنولوجيا
وكل هذه القضايا الكبرى مثل الانترنت
قضايا المستقبل يقول انه خلال السنوات
العشر او ال 15 التي سوف تاتي على اوروبا
ان تتركز او ان تركز اهتمامها بكل هذه
القضايا هو ان تستعيد كافه المصانع كافه
المرافق النوويه ما ذكرته الان سيفعلق
بالاستقلال الاستراتيجي اسال عنه ضيف من
باريس جيم تاوند كيف تنظر واشنطن الى ما
ذكره الرئيس الفرنسي فيما يتعلق بما سماه
الاستقلال الاستراتيجي بالنسبه لاوروبا
كيف تنظر واشنطن الى هذا المصطلح
نحن نفهم هذا المصطلح على انه
استقلال الاستراتيجي هو ان مشكل لان ليس
لاي مشكله ازاعه ان تقف اوروبا لوحدها
استقلال لنفسها وتكون لديها قوه صناعيه
كبيره والدفاع قوي ولا تعتمد وتكون تابعه
للولايات المتحده هذا نفضله ايضا
وطالما ان الاستقلال الاستراتيجي ليس شيء
ضد الولايات المتحده او يقف ضدها او يحاول
ان يضعف التحالف عبر العطله
وايضا مساله التحالف ضمن ذلك ليس مضرا
بالولايات المتحده فاعتقد ان هذا الشيء
يجعله اوروبا شريكا اقوى اقل اعتمادا
علينا
شريك يستطيع ان يحمل اكثر من الثقل
ولا يطلب وان لا يطلب من فرنسا اوروبا ان
تتبع الولايات المتحده لدينا مشاكل وقضايا
في اسيا هل افهم من كلامك سيتا واعذرني
على المقاطعه ما ذكرته الان بان اوروبا
تتحمل جزء من العيب ولا تعتمد علينا
نوع من التهديد المبطن لا تطلبوا حمايه
واشنطن ومن ثم تتكلمون عن الاستقلال
الاستراتيجي
ليس تهديد كلها ليس اطلاقا بل هذا مجرد
تعبير من قبل ولايه مده سنوات عديده انه
فيما يتعلق الدفاع على اوروبي نحن نرى ان
نحمل عبئا اكثر من ما يفعله حلفاء
الاوروبيين ونحن منذ سنوات نطلب منه حلفاء
الاوروبيين ان يفقوا اكثر او يزيدوا
ميزانياته في الدفاعيه ويزيدوا شراء
المعدات والتدريب العسكري ليكون له وجودا
عسكريين اقوى بحث نستطيع ان نتشاطر الدفاع
عن التحالف عبر الاطلسي وعلى اوروبا طيب
سيد فرجتي فيما يتعلق بهذا الملف ملف
تايوان كيف نفهم مساله الاستقلال
الاستراتيجي عندما يتعلق الامر بين مواجهه
بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم الصيني من
جهه والامريكي من جهه في ملف خطير وملف
تايوان
تحدث ايمانيال ماكو
المواقف اليوم ولا يتحدث عن
مواقف امنيه لها علاقه بالصين وتايوان
يقول اليوم
ليس على اوروبا ان تدخل في هذه اللعبه
اوان تنجرا او ان تكون لها تبعيه
تجاهها طرف دون اخر
اما بالنسبه الى المستقبل فالامور قد
تتغير
ولكنه يستند الى مبادئ عامه بدون ان يدخل
في تفاصيل استراتيجيه ولا تكتيكيه بالنسبه
الى موضوع تايوان يقولوا ان مبدا
استقلاليه اوروبا وتعزيز الاستقلاليه وهذا
ما سمعناه طبعا وهذا ما تريد الولايات
المتحده بحسب ضيفكم الكريم اذا هذا هو
مبداه الا وهو تعزيز استقلاليه الولايات
المتحده
التي ربما لديها مصالح مختلفه في مواقع
اخرى وبالتالي على اوروبا ان تتمكن من
معالجه مشاكلها ولا تعمل مشاكل الاقتصاديه
اذا هذا هو الموقف وليس ضد الولايات
المتحده وحتى لم يذكر وهنا سؤال لسيد جيم
تاونسن الرئيس ماكرون كان اكثر وضوحا من
مصطلح الاستقلال الاستراتيجي اوروبا الا
تكون
تابعا لواشنطن هذه الكلمه اضع تحتها اكثر
من خط
اننا علينا ان نفهم ان اوروبا لا تتبع
الولايات المتحده كما تفعل الدميه
كيف خلف خلف سيدها كلا ليس هكذا العلاقه
بين اوروبا ولايه المتحده مع فرنسا نحن
الشركاء نجلس الى مائده طويله كبيره هي
مائده
النيتو
الاجتماع في واشنطن مع سيدنا
توجه وارادت لنا ان جميع نسير عليه علينا
نعبر ما هو هذا
الاتجاه فيمكن الاخرين ان يوافق او لا
يتفقوا لا يمكن ان نجبرهم او نقوم باي شيء
لسحب الامم والجره الينا لان كلنا لدينا
مصلحه في اسيا اوروبا لديها مصلحه فرنسا
لديها مصلحه فرنسا لديها الكثير من
المصالح في اسيا في
الجنوب الهادي وايضا لديهم شراكه تجاريه
مع الصين والاستقرار في الصين مهم لاوروبا
كما هو مهم المتحده وبالتالي لدينا شكرا
لا يشعرون بقلق ازاء الصين
يا سيد نائب وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون اوروبا وكذلك لضيفي من باريس
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي واعتذر فقط ادركنا
الوقت
[موسيقى]
كانت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان القياده العليا في الفينتاجون
قيدت تدفق المعلومات يوم الجمعه ردا على
تسريب وثائق سريه عن حرب اوكرانيا واضافت
الصحيفه ان تقييد البنتا لتدفق المعلومات
صارم بشكل غير عادي ويكشف عن مستوى عالي
من الذعر في اوساط القياده وعبر مسؤول
استخباري اوروبي للصحيفه عن القلق
الاوروبي من امكانيه تقييد واشنطن وصولا
الحلفاء الى تقارير الاستخبارات
المستقبليه
اما في اسرائيل فنفى مكتب رئيس الوزراء في
بيان باسم هيئه الاستخبارات والمهمات
الخاصه المصادمه جاء في التسريبات ونقلته
الصحافه الامريكيه عن تشجيع المصاد على
التظاهر ضد حكومه نتنياه بنيامين نتنياهو
وافاد مكتب رئيس الحكومه نيابه عن الموساد
عبر حسابه على تويتر بانما نشر في الصحافه
الامريكيه خاطئ تماما ولا اساس له من
الصحه واضاف المكتب ان مسؤلي الموساد لم
يشجعوا العاملين في هيئه الاستخبارات على
التظاهر ضد الحكومه او على اي نشاط سياسي
[موسيقى]
صبرنا معكم في هذا الحصاد ولكن قبل ذلك
نتابع هذه اللقطات من باحات المسجد الاقصى
وفيها تبدو الاجواء هادئه بعد يوم التوتر
اثر اقتحام المستوطنين صباح اليوم فيما
تتجدد الدعوات من قبل المتطرفين لمواصله
الاقتحامات حتى انتهاء عيد الفصح اليهودي
الاربعاء
القادم كما هدد بذلك وزير الامن بنجفير
وهذه صور مباشره من ساحه المسجد
الاقصى بعد اداء صلاه التراويح وبعدما
انفض المصلون في انتظار يوم الغد
والتهديدات ربما ايضا
باقتحامات اخرى
لساحات وللمسجد الاقصى من قبل المتطرفين
والمستوطنين اليهود
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده الى التطورات المشهد الاسرائيلي
مع تصاعد الجبهات سلطت او سلطاته سلطت
الهجمات الاخيره على اسرائيل من عده مناطق
الضوء على كابوس مواجهه متعدده الجبهات
وهو سيناريو ظل يقلق قاده جيشها مؤكدين ان
القدره على مواجهه ذلك ما زالت دون
المستوى المطلوب فما هي ابرز تلك الجبهات
الجبهه الاكثر نشاطا هي قطاع غزه حيث تشن
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بين الحين والاخر
هجمات صاروخيه ردا على اعتداءات قوات
الاحتلال وهجماته وفي الايام الاخيره
اطلقت فصائل المقاومه في القطاع رشقات
صاروخيه على مستوطنات في غلاف غزه
اما الجبهه الثانيه فهي جبهه جنوب لبنان
التي يسميها الاحتلال الجبهه الشماليه
وهذه مزدوجه الاداء فتمت حزب الله
بترسالته الساروخيه الكبير وهناك ايضا
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في لبنان التي تهمتها
اسرائيل بالوقوف وراء اطلاق عشرات القذائف
عليها الاسبوع الماضي كما دخلت ايضا على
الخط جبهه الجولان السوريه المحتل هذه
المره حيث تساقطت على المنطقه المحتله عده
صواريخ قبل يومين قادمه من داخل الاراضي
السوريه
ولاحقا شن الجيش الاسرائيلي قصفا بريا
وجويا على مواقع في سوريا اذا هي جبهات
مجتمعه يتزامن تحركها مع تطورات اخرى
تواجهها اسرائيل بينها مشهد التصعيد
فالضفه الغربيه والقدس وكذلك داخل الخط
الاخضر
تحسبا لذلك السيناريو المخيف بالنسبه
للجانب الاسباني تواصل اسرائيل منذ سنوات
رفعه جاهزيتها القتاليه وكذلك الحربيه فقد
اجرت عام 2021 مناورات عسكريه تحاكي حربا
من عده جبهات شاركت طبعا في هذه المناورات
اجهزه وقطاعات عسكريه باشراف قوات الجبهه
الداخليه في جيش الاحتلال اسرائيل تعول
على المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
المتطوره التي تمنحها ما تسميه تفوقا
نوعيا وكميا على كل دول المنطقه للبحث هذه
المقاربه وهذه التطورات ربما المرتقبه
معنا من غزه الدكتور صالح النعامي الباحث
المتخصص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه دكتور صالح
عندما نتكلم عن تعدد الجبهات ما المقاربه
الاسرائيليه ما الحسابات الاسرائيليه في
التصعيد او في التخفيف كما حدث في اليومين
الماضيين
واضح الاستاذ عبد القادر بانه تعدد
الجبهات وتفجر عده جبهات في ان يعد كما
اسلفتم كابوسا بالنسبه لاسرائيل لانه
القدرات الذاتيه للجيش الاحتلال لا تمكنه
ولا تاهله لمواجهه تفجر مثل هذه الجبهات
سيما انه نحن نتحدث عن
تفجر الجبهات الداخليه عنا الان الكثير من
انويه المشاه في جيش الاحتلال الان مستلبه
يعني مستنزفه داخل الضفه الغربيه اليوم
وزير الحرب الاسرائيلي جراند اصدر تعليمات
بانه حتى يتم دفع لقوات من الجيش الى داخل
تل ابيب وهذا يعني تعتبر سابقه في تاريخ
اسرائيل اسرائيل تتواجس انه هناك توجه على
الاقل بالنسبه لايران وبالنسبه لحزب الله
لتغيير قواعد الاشتباك وقد حدث هذا
على شكل السماح للفصائل الفلسطينيه وحكمه
التام اسرائيل حركه حماس الصواريخ من جنوب
لبنان اطلاق الصواريخ من من الجولان سيما
انه تقدير الاسرائيلي بيقول بانه تقليل
روسيا لتواجدها في داخل سوريا ساعد ساعد
ايران على بس نهوض على على اماكن اكثر
وعزز قدرتها على
وعزز الثقه الايرانيين يعني تغيير نمط
سلوكه حتى الان كانت ايران تستقبل الضربات
الاسرائيلي ولا ترد هناك مؤشرات لدى
اسرائيل بانه بانه لدى ايران توجه اخر
وهذا تمثل قبل اسبوع باطلاق الطائره بدون
طيار من من سوريا باتجاه الجليل المحتال
اليوم اطلاق صواريخ من من
سوريا من سوريا هل هذا ما يفسر
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بالقول بعد اطلاق
الصواريخ سواء من لبنان او من غزه او من
سوريا قالت بان فوتنا فرصه لمشروع او
لمحاوله
ايرانيه لحسابات معينه هل هذا يتوافق مع
ما ذكرته الصحف الاسرائيليه
ان السؤال لم اسمع جيدا استاذ عبد القادر
سالتك ما ذكرته الان عن هذا البعد
الايراني وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه قالت
باننا فوتنا فرصه على حسابات ايرانيه
تزامنت مع اطلاق الصواريخ من هذه الجبهات
الثلاث
الى اجل محدود اسرائيل ليس بامكانها ان
تواصل هذا النمط من السلوك قوه الردع
الاسرائيليه الان في الحضيض قدره اسرائيل
على فرض قواعد الاشتباك تراجعت الى حد
كبير الاكثر من ذلك هو البعد السياسي
اليوم عبد القادر استطلاعات الراي يعني
دللت على انه الاحزاب التي تشكل الحكومه
في اسرائيل قد تراجعت شعبيتها بشكل كبير
وغير مسبوق وبالتالي اسرائيل في تقدير
ستغير هذه المقاربه ولكن لكنها ستختار
الساحات الاكثر الاكثر راحه لها يعني على
سبيل المثال اسرائيل ستستثني بشكل مطلق اي
سيناريو يفضي الى مواجهه شامله مع حزب
الله لسبب بسيط انه طابعه لسان الصاروخيه
لدى حزب الله سواء على صعيد مدى الصواريخ
الطويل الرؤوس المتفجره المتفجره الثقيله
الصواريخ ذات دقه الاصابه العاليه تجعل
مواجهه مع حزب الله مواجهه يعني يعني
محفوظه بكثير من المخاطر لذلك هم الان
يعني وقد بداوا في هذا اليوم بسوريا شكرا
لسوريا الضغط على النظام تحديدا عبر
السيارات
الفرقه الرابعه التابعه اعتذر منك من غزه
الدكتور صالح النعامي الباحثه المختص في
شؤون الاسرائيليه
بدا نصل الى ختام هذا الحصاد الى اللقاء
باذن الله
[موسيقى]